[Musique]
pardon mais si la chance vous avez vu
passer des hommes ya combien de temps un
peu près dix minutes
[Musique]
c'était paraît-il le bon temps
quelques-uns s'en souviennent encore à
paris au début du siècle aux environs de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
une époque hélas révolue on se
retournait alors sur une automobile
aujourd'hui la curiosité c'est un
attelage de la circulation
nous sommes allés rendre visite à lundi
dernier gardien dan à paris ils sont
vraiment correct nous laisse passer mais
par contre j'ai eu quelques mois je te
luxembourg et si j'avais pas vraiment
attention pensez vous toujours la
relègue aussi bien que répète que sur
les automobilistes
alors ils m'auraient rentrer ma dette
envers complète pour alors on savait
comment que ça se passe pourtant
légèrement furieux je lui ai dit non
c'est philippe qui propose à tort et à
travers comme on dit ben je peux pas
aller plus loin c'est s'arrêter tout
mais par contre je savais le principal
le cdur c'est le soir le gars des gens
qui sont très gentils mais par contre si
on n'a pas combien de polyvore je peux
pas dire le nom et enfin surpris de voir
des ânes dans la lah on pensait donc ici
surtout qu'ici ça fait des années que ça
existe avant d'essayer cette première
fois qu'on rencontre des hommes dans la
circulation
alors non j'en vois tous les jours non
plus que d'habitude et vous n'êtes vous
pas un peu perdu au milieu de ce que tu
es avec les agents de police vous avez
des petits problèmes mais alors est-ce
qu'il saura je dois dire ce n'est pas
maintenant qu'on toit jantes et ils
disent on est très bien en contact
au contraire quand ton petit boy qu'on
embête et tout sur tout les premiers à
nous dépanner comprenez vous il a récusé
l'accusation ils ont pas pardon mais
c'est l'agent est ce que les petits
hommes dans la circulation vous pose des
problèmes pas du tout les problèmes
c'est déjà dur juste à traverser la
demoiselle goût des jets d'eau est ce
que le code de la route prévoit quelque
chose justement pour les animaux et
notamment pour les petits à les animaux
sont accompagnés n'y a pas de problème
ils sont toujours
avec une personne qui les guide et
dramatiquement il s'arrête au feu comme
comme un piéton pareils exactement
[Musique]